salut les gaules j'espère que vous allez
bien on termine à cette série sur les
programmes des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle avec celui d'emmanuel
macron le candidat dont le programme est
sorti le plus tard alors comme pour tous
les candidats l'objectif c'est de vous
donner un bon aperçu de ce qu'il propose
pour les cinq années à venir la
particularité c'est que spoiler emmanuel
macron était à l'elysée déjà depuis cinq
ans alors pour ce qui est du bilan d'
emmanuel macron sur ces cinq années à
l'elysée on a essayé de faire une vidéo
sauf que pour être tout à fait
transparent avec vous on n'était pas
complètement satisfait du résultat c'est
donner quelque chose on voulait
davantage détaillé un certain nombre
d'éléments bref du coup on en train de
voir chez manquent pas sortir une vidéo
de ce type là du coup dans les prochains
jours mais cela dépendra de ce qu'on
arrive à faire avec tout ça en attendant
quoi qu'il en soit je vous ai mis en
descriptions plusieurs dossiers réalisés
notamment par des médias de vraiment
tous les bords politiques qui ont fait
justement ce travail de bilan du
quinquennat je vous invite donc à
prendre le temps de lire quelques uns
pour vous faire votre propre opinion et
évidemment je tiendrai au courant enfin
avant de commencer je souhaite la
bienvenue quand même à tous les nouveaux
qui suivent la chaîne ces derniers jours
et par ailleurs je tiens à vous dire
aussi que vous pouvez vous abonner à
notre compte instagram leconte qui
s'appelle hugo décrypte on poste des
présentations des programmes des
comparaisons sur des sujets précis ça
vient en complément donc notamment du
format des actes jours qu'on a aussi sur
instagram bref n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner si jamais ce n'est pas encore le
cas vous êtes déjà quasiment 2 millions
à suivre ce compte
alors comme pour tous les candidats
commençons tout de même par une petite
présentation emmanuel macron à 44 ans
est le plus jeune de tous les candidats
il a fait l'école nationale
d'administration
une école donc l' ena qui forme les
hauts fonctionnaires français avant de
devenir banquier d'affaires à la banque
rothschild tonton quatre ans en 2012 il
devient conseiller du nouveau président
françois hollande qui le nommera deux
ans plus tard en 2014 ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique
il occupe cette fonction jusqu'en 2016
année où il fonde son propre mouvement
politique qui s'appelle en marche il
démissionne à ce moment-là du
gouvernement la suite vous la connaissez
il est élu président de la république en
2007 avec 24% des voix au premier tour
et 66% des voix au second tour contre
34% pour marine le pen ça c'était donc
pour la présentation maintenant voyons
ensemble dix mesures majeures de son
programme première mesure première des
onze grandes dimensions de son programme
est mené de macron veut que l'on
travaille plus et plus longtemps il veut
en fait repousser progressivement l'âge
du départ à la retraite à 65 ans alors
qu'il fixait à 62 ans aujourd'hui les
métiers pénibles et les personnes en
situation de handicap pourront toutefois
partir plus tôt il veut par ailleurs
encourager le cumul emploi retraite pour
les volontaires c'est-à-dire le fait
pour un retraité de reprendre s'ils le
souhaitent une activité professionnelle
pour cumuler un salaire et une pension
de retraite s'ils le souhaitent il
propose d'ailleurs de mettre en place un
système pour rémunérer les volontaires
proche de la retraite qui souhaitent
partager leur expérience par exemple
pour faire de l'aide aux devoirs ou
encore pour aider une entreprise bref
tout ce qui touche à la transmission de
savoir faire par ailleurs sur les
retraites s'il souhaite aussi que la
pension minimale que touche à un
retraité soit 2100 euros par mois contre
645 euros aujourd'hui autre mesure qui
concerne le temps de travail mais niait
macron veut favoriser l'utilisation de
ce qu'il appelle un compte épargne temps
alors sans entrer dans les détails
techniques se serait en fait un
dispositif qui permettrait de pouvoir
accumuler des heures de travail qui
aurait été fait et bien en plus pour les
transformer en congés un moment de sa
vie le but ce serait de moduler en fait
son temps de travail en fonction des
périodes de la vie on a envie de
travailler plus ou moins et de prendre
des congés à un moment donné dans sa vie
par exemple pendant plusieurs mois
puisque typiquement dans les premières
années de notre vie on aurait peut-être
travailler 40 heures par semaine autre
mesure de son programme qui a beaucoup
fait réagir elle concerne le rsa donc le
revenu de solidarité active une aide à
destination des plus démunis d'un peu
plus de 550 euros par mois pour une
personne seule essentiellement en fait
aujourd'hui pour les plus de 25 ans et
bien emmanuel macron veut désormais que
cette allocation qui le rsa soit versée
en contrepartie d'une activité de 15 à
20 heures par semaine 15 à 20 heures
d'accompagnement ou de formation
concrètement ces 15 à 20 heures serait
donc obligatoire sauf situation
exceptionnelle avec par exemple des
mères seules qui n'auraient pas le temps
ou encore des personnes en situation
d'addiction et selon le parti la
république en marche ça pourrait être
par exemple des formations des périodes
d'immersion en entreprise des stages de
coaching des cours de langues ou encore
des formations pour passer le permis de
conduire aux mesures emmanuel macron
veut mettre en place le versement à la
source des aides financières et des
allocations sociales comme le rsa
justement ou encore la prime d'activité
ou alors les aides au logement en gros
pour faire simple jusqu'ici pour chaque
et de social faut en général remplir un
formulaire différents et se rendre
parfois sur un site différent et là en
l'occurrence il suffirait de remplir à
un seul endroit toutes les informations
sur votre situation et suite à ça et
bien toutes les aides auxquelles vous
pourriez avoir droit et bien vous serez
versé directement sur votre compte en
banque sans avoir besoin donc de
demander chacune spécifiquement et les
unes après les autres je vous la fait
courte mais c'est donc une volonté de
simplification emmanuel macron juge que
c'est une bonne manière de lutter contre
la pauvreté notamment à cause du non
recours aujourd'hui aux aides c'est à
dire le fait que bien un stand de
personnes aujourd'hui n'ont pas accès et
ne bénéficient pas de certaines aides
dont ils pourraient bénéficier
simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
ces démarches et ce versement à la
source pourrait concerner 20 millions de
personnes cinquième mesure cette fois ci
qui concerne les salaires emmanuel
macron propose de tripler la prime qui
s'appelle la prime macron c'est en fait
un dispositif qui avait mis en place
quand il était ministre de l'économie de
françois hollande concrètement avec ce
dispositif aujourd'hui un employeur peut
verser une prime exceptionnelle à ses
salariés allant jusqu'à 1000 euros par
an sans charge ni impôt en gros c'est
l'entreprise faire c'est disons 800
euros de prime et bien c'est 800 euros
qui vont directement dans le compte du
salarié et bien désormais menu mac on
veut que ce montant puisse aller jusqu'à
3000 euros par an c'est donc une manière
d'inciter les entreprises à une
augmentation des revenus un peu à la
même manière qu eric zemmour avec sa
prime zéro charge mais contrairement à
tous les candidats de gauche par exemple
il ne propose pas une augmentation du
salaire minimum alors que par exemple
jean luc mélenchon de prôner citer que
lui propose de passer le smic à 1400
euros net par mois l'autre mesure que je
voulais voir aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
de nouvelle en soi mais m'anime lacrouts
souhaite généraliser le s est nu dans le
service national universel
alors ce s est nu s'adresse aux jeunes
de 15 à 17 ans il s'agit d'une mission
citoyenne d'un mois ou plus si jamais on
le souhaite et en gros plusieurs jeunes
sont réunis pendant ce séjour d'un mois
pour suivre des activités sportives des
activités citoyennes ou encore des
moments de débats alors jusqu'à présent
le fmi n'était pas obligatoire mais donc
emmanuel macron souhaite à terme le
rendre obligatoire par ailleurs emmanuel
macron veut aussi motiver les jeunes à
s'engager dans la durée en devenant
réservistes de l'armée française pour ça
il propose pour les jeunes qui
s'engagent pendant cinq ans de leur
offrir une allocation pour financer
leurs études à hauteur de 2500 euros par
an ainsi que le financement de leur
permis de conduire par ailleurs plus
largement concernant l'armée comme les
candidats de droite principalement
emmanuel macron veut davantage investir
dans l'armée il souhaite augmenter le
budget militaire à 50 milliards d'euros
par an en 2025 alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui d'environ 41 milliards
d'euros marine le pen propose quant à
elle de l'augmenter à 55 milliards
d'euros par an en 2027 et vallées
pécresse à 65 milliards d'euros par an
en 2030 senti que pour terminer eric
zemmour vise un budget de 70 milliards
d'euros à l'horizon 2030 autre mesure qu
on pourrait noter comme beaucoup de
candidats et méline macron parle des
déserts médicaux ces zones donc en
france où l'accès aux soins est
compliqué car il n'ya souvent pas de
médecin ou alors d'hôpital à moins de 30
minutes de chez soi pour cela il propose
notamment de nommer des référentes santé
pour des actes simples en gros il s'agit
de donner le pouvoir un pharmacien ou
encore un infirmier de renouveler une
ordonnance ou alors de faire d'autres
choses simples de ce type sans avoir
recours forcément typiquement un médecin
généraliste est par ailleurs il veut
également recruté 50 mille infirmiers et
aides soignants de plus dans les ehpad
7e mesure désormais qui concerne l'école
et mener macron veut augmenter les
heures de français et de mathématiques
en primaire et en sixième comme
d'ailleurs la candidate de droite
valérie pécresse mais sans préciser cela
dit le nombre d'heure exacte il veut
également bien remettre les
mathématiques dont le tronc commun du
lycée comme le français les langues ou
encore l'histoire géo c'est à dire que
bien se serait renseigné peu importe les
spécialités ensuite que l'on choisit
minimes macron veut aussi augmenter les
heures de sport avec 30 minutes par jour
en primaire dès la rentrée prochaine et
deux heures supplémentaires chaque
semaine au collège sachant que pour ses
trente minutes de sport par jour en
primaire il n'a pas forcément détaillé
comment est ce que ça pourrait être mise
en place il souhaite aussi à augmenter
de 50% les périodes de stages en
entreprise pour les lycéens et les
étudiants et par ailleurs rémunérés donc
ces stages pour les lycéens il veut
également réformé par coups reçus mais
là-dessus pareil on n'a pas vraiment les
détails de cette évolution est sûre
concrètement ce qu'ils voudraient
changer et enfin pour terminer il veut
engager une grande réforme du lycée
professionnel mais là aussi on n'a pas
forcément davantage d'informations 8e
mesure désormais emmanuel macron aveu
que la france continue de miser sur
l'énergie nucléaire il a annoncé en
février on en a parlé dans les études
jour la volonté de construire six
réacteurs nucléaires nouvelle génération
et huit réacteurs supplémentaires
pourraient être construits d'ici à 2050
selon lui il est en fait indispensable
de miser aujourd'hui au vu de la
situation sur le nucléaire pour réduire
nos émissions de co2 mais aussi pour
assurer une certaine indépendance
énergétique est à noter qu'en parallèle
de ce développement du nucléaire il
souhaite aussi développer l'énergie
solaire il veut également implanté 50
parc éolien en mer d'ici à 2050 enfin
autre mesure concernant l'écologie mais
le maquereau souhaite rénover plus de
700 mille logements par an afin qu'ils
consomment justement moins d'énergie la
9e mesure désormais elle concerne
l'immigration emmanuel macron veut
réformer le droit d'asile et le droit de
séjour en gros il veut que l'on décide
plus vite qui est éligible et que l'on
exclut ce plus rapidement ceux qui ne le
sont pas par ailleurs les conditions
d'obtention des titres de séjour seront
durcies en effet ils ne seront accordés
qu'à ceux qui réussissent un examen de
français et qui s'insère
professionnellement dixième et dernière
mesure qu on pourrait citer mesnil
macron veut renforcer les liens avec
l'union européenne que ce soit par
exemple en matière de défense d'économie
d'énergie ou encore d'écologie il plaide
notamment pour la création d'une armée
européenne
une mesure qu'il avait déjà proposé
durant son quinquennat en gros
contrairement à pas mal de candidats à
la présidentielle 2002 macron ne
souhaite pas que la france sorte de
l'otan il souhaite rester au sein de
l'otan mais il veut par ailleurs donc
qu'il y ait une véritable armée
européenne
voilà donc pour dix mesures principales
du programme des beignets macron on
termine par quelques autres mesures
comme on fait avec tous les candidats qu
on pourrait citer emmanuel macron
souhaite qu'il soit possible de réaliser
un bilan de santé complet et gratuit à
25 ans 45 ans et 60 ans ensuite il n'est
pas favorable à la légalisation du
cannabis
il veut aussi à supprimer la redevance
télé 138 euros donc payé chaque année
par les foyers pour financer
l'audiovisuel public mais il ne souhaite
pas pour autant mettre fin aux services
publics dans les médias contrairement à
d'autres candidats il souhaite permettre
à tous les couples vivent ensemble de
réduire leur impôt comme s'ils étaient
mariés ou pacsés il propose aussi
d'ouvrir une réflexion d'un groupe ii
citoyen qui pourrait aboutir à la
légalisation de l'euthanasie et enfin il
propose d'engager une discussion pour
que la corse est davantage d'autonomie
vous le savez peut-être suivi les
actualités du jour sur notre chaîne ça
fait suite notamment au décès de
l'indépendantiste corse yvan colonna
voilà donc pour le décryptage du
programme d' emmanuel macron n'hésitez
pas évidemment à vous abonner pour ne
pas louper les autres vidéos qui vont
sortir dans les prochains jours sur la
présidentielle mais pas que vous le
savez ce qu'on prépare d'autres choses
et notamment je peux vous dire qu'il va
sortir dans quelques jours une vidéo
avec stromae que j'ai réalisé avec lui
il y a quelques jours bref n'hésitez pas
du coup à vous abonner je vous voulez
plus d'information sur le programme de
tous les candidats aussi même chose au
rendez vous je lisais aussi sur
instagram pour découvrir d'autres
contenus au quotidien notamment et bien
des comparatifs entre les programmes des
candidats qui peuvent vous intéresser à
l'écouté je crois que j'ai tout dis
prenez soin de vous présenter vos
proches et on se dit ah très vite